hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
at the beginning of fear and trembling
Kierkegaard is going to tell us four
little stories essentially
reinterpretations imagining what it must
have been like for Abraham on his way
and coming back from the commanded
sacrifice of his son Isaac why does he
begin a work of philosophy this way
well Abraham is really the central
figure and Abraham is being used here as
a way to try to understand faith and it
is being done from a philosophical
perspective that philosophy can use
narrative so that's part of what is is
going on here Abraham if you think about
his cultural significance is often
called the father of faith and we even
speak about the Abrahamic religions
referring primarily to Judaism
Christianity and Islam as the largest
branches of that entire family and why
do we talk about Abraham as the father
of faith this is part of what this book
is attempting to grapple with so we
begin with a narrative and you can find
this narrative in its original form in
the book of Genesis as a matter of fact
Abraham takes up quite a bit of space in
the book of Genesis and this this
incident of the sacrifice of Isaac takes
up an entire chapter so Abraham is a
person who is called by God he leaves
his ancestral home in Mesopotamia and
begins traveling following the the call
to go to the essentially Promised Land
where God tells him that he is going to
make him
[Music]
a mode or a vehicle of blessing for the
peoples of the earth so there's a
long-standing relationship developed
between Abraham and God and it includes
Abraham's family as well what ends up
happening is towards the end of their
their lives Abraham and Sarah don't have
any any children and this is kind of a
catastrophe not one that's easy for us
in the present day to relate to unless
we value childhood and birth and all of
the things that go along with that
generativity passing on life from
generation to generation but for ancient
peoples this was a terrible curse in
crisis
Sarah is barren well Abraham isn't
because he has a son with his handmaid
Hagar and this means that the promise
that God is making seems to be difficult
to fulfill how possibly can Abraham do
anything for the world once he's gone if
he's not going to have any progeny and
what ends up happening is there is a
miracle they have a child Isaac and
Abraham loves his his son in fact as
Kierkegaard is going to stress
Isaac is in certain respects the best
thing in his life it's the best thing
that he has to offer not a thing in the
same sense as other things but a person
and God has already promised Abraham
that through Abraham many peoples will
be blessed many generations the entire
world in a way here is where we come to
the crux this is why the story matters
so much it's not just that God blessed
him so much because he he trusted in God
and look how to follow a
hams example this is not prosperity
theology this is rather the theology of
crisis of paradox of anxiety and
distress God commands Abraham to take
his son and travel to Mount Moriah and
sacrifice him their sacrifice in that
time was a very common occurrence blood
sacrifice
typically it was sacrifice of animals
you know for example a lamb although you
know we read and the Greeks about
sacrificing entire Hecate homes of bulls
and cows and things like that this is
very common you would slit the animal's
throat very often there was a aspect in
which the the meat from the animal would
be shared not only with the deity but
also with the person carrying out the
sacrifice and other people attending it
so God seems to be commanding Abraham to
do something terrible not only is he
asking him to sacrifice a human being
he's asking him to sacrifice his only
son and to add more to this God seems to
be contradicting himself in this very
asking why because God has said listen
Abraham I'm going to bless you I'm gonna
bless the whole world through you and
presumably amber Abraham can assume
Isaac is a central part of that so for
God to say sacrifice Isaac to me is a
very heavy weight on Abraham's shoulders
Abraham goes he takes Isaac Isaac even
asks along the way hey Dad where's the
sacrifice where's the animal for it and
Abraham says well God's going to provide
that and they get him to the altar and
Abraham has the knife out and he's ready
to sacrifice his own son and an angel
says don't do that and he finds a
suitable animal substitute stuck over in
the brush brings him over in sacrifices
now imagine the ride home from that and
that's exactly what Kierkegaard does so
after we get this narrative in the
background Kierkegaard gives us multiple
interpretations of this story in the
first one he says it was early in the
morning Abraham you know takes Isaac
they ride in silence for three days he
leaves the servants behind he's not
going to hide from Isaac where the walk
is taking him he lays his hand on
Isaac's head and blessing Isaac could
not understand him he clasped Abraham's
knees he pleads for his life and Abraham
lifts the boy up and walks on holding
his hand his words are full of comfort
and admonition Isaac could not
understand him and he seizes him by the
bee by the chest throws him to the
ground so stupid boy do you think I'm
your father I'm at a dollar do you think
it's God's command no it's my desire and
Isaac cries out to God in this version
of the narrative God in heaven have
mercy on me God of Abraham have mercy on
me if I have no father on earth you be
my father Abraham says softly to himself
Lord God in heaven I thank you it's
better that he believes me a monster
than that he should lose faith in you
and each of these narratives ends with a
story about how a child is weaned
he says when a child is weaned the
mother blackens her breast it would be
hard to the breast look inviting when
the child must not have it and each of
the stories is going to conclude and in
that way so the first narration that
that Kierkegaard is doing here is
building off of this original narration
and then reinterpreting it imagining
what it must be like for Abraham in that
situation Abraham puts on a false front
so that his child will not
lose faith even though he's going to
sacrifice him
second one is shorter he says it was
early in the morning Abraham arose he
embraced Sarah Sarah kissed Isaac
they rode along the road in silence
Abraham stared continuously and fixedly
at the ground until the fourth day he
sees the mountain he arranges the
firewood binds Isaac draws the knife
sees the RAM that God has selected
sacrificed and went home and here's the
key to this interpretation from that day
henceforth Abraham was old he could not
forget that God had ordered him to do
this Isaac flourished as before but
Abraham's eyes were darkened he saw joy
no more this is a second possible
imaginary interpretation of what is
taking place in the Abraham story the
third one
Abraham arose kisses Sarah Sarah kissed
Isaac Abraham rides thoughtfully through
the row the road and the desert he
climbs Mount Moriah he throws himself
down on his face prays to God to forgive
him his sin that he had been willing to
sacrifice Isaac that the father had
forgotten his duty to the son here's
where the kicker is he often rode his
lonesome road but he found no peace he
could not comprehend that it was a sin
he'd been willing to sacrifice to God
the best that he had the possession for
which he himself would have gladly died
many times and if it was a sin he had if
he had not loved Isaac in this manner he
could not understand that it could be
forgiven for what more terrible sin was
there it culminates in a new kind of
catastrophe and then he gives us another
fourth interpretation Abraham takes
takes leave of Sarah Eliezer follows him
along until he turns back again they
come to Mount Moriah makes everything
ready for the sacrifice but when he
turned away
Isaac saw that Abraham's left hand was
clenched in despair that a shudder went
through his whole body but Abraham drew
the knife then they returned home again
but Isaac had law
the faith not a word is ever said of
this in the world
Isaac never talked to anyone what he'd
seen Abraham did not suspect anyone had
seen it
now why is Kierkegaard beginning with us
he's saying imagine a guy who is
meditating upon this short terse
biblical story of Abraham and trying to
figure out what's going on there
one might run through such imaginative
interpretive variations and notice that
in these it's not just about shifting
the characters around changing the
scenery it's about the interior
dispositions of the person do they lose
faith that they have faith what goes on
in their minds not just faith to by the
way but joy youth sadness despair all of
these are potentially parts of the
Abraham story according to Kierkegaard
now we get to another important set of
points Abraham is in the next section
depicted as being the greatest character
card calls us a eulogy on Abraham a
eulogy is a speech of praise and he says
that Abraham is one among many figures
who we might look up to he tells us that
as God created man and woman so he
created the hero and the poet or the
orator the hero is the person who acts
who does things the poet the orator he
says can do nothing the hero does he can
only admire love and delight in him yet
he too is happy no less than one is for
the hero is so to speak his better
nature with which he is enamored yet
happy the other is not himself that his
love can be admiration and so it is
because of the poet or the orator that
we have the stories of the heroes
passed down to us the fundamental
question here running throughout the
entire work is can we look at Abraham as
in a sense a biblical hero the way we
can with many other biblical figures
Abraham will bring up the judge Japeth
who is has to sacrifice his own daughter
Japeth is more of a tragic hero than a
hero of faith we might think of David we
might think of Moses we might think of
so many other figures Deborah Judith are
they heroes in the same sense that the
Greek heroes or pick other
cross-cultural heroes of Saint Knorr or
Indian or Iranian mythology and legends
or is there something different going on
in the Abraham story
Kierkegaard believes that the latter is
the case so he tells us everyone in the
world was great in his own way and
everyone in proportion to the greatness
of that which he loved he who loved
himself became great by virtue of
himself he who loved other people became
great by his devotedness he who loved
God became greatest of all and he says
one person became great by expecting the
possible another by expecting the
eternal but he who expected the
impossible became the greatest of all
who is the one who expected the
impossible Abraham Abraham is somehow
superlatively great great beyond the
greatness of those that we can relate to
so much easier he goes on and he says he
who struggled with the world became
great by conquering the world he who
struggled with himself became great by
conquering himself but he who struggled
with God became the greatest of all he
goes on and says there was one who
conquered everything by his power and
there was one who conquered God by his
powerlessness
there was one who relied upon himself
and gained everything there was one who
in the security of his own strength
sacrificed everything but the one who
believed God was the greatest of all so
Abraham is different than the heroes
that we're thinking of as a matter of
fact we'll talk about this elsewhere if
we think of him solely in terms of
heroes he's actually a bad guy he's
willing to sacrifice his own son and not
because the country demands it or
anything along those lines where he said
well there's a greater good it's because
he hears his voice that he says is God
telling him to do it even though it
seems totally irrational so Abraham is
going to be the father of faith and this
raises the question for us what is faith
we can certainly rule out some simple
answers it's not just a stupid blind
belief that's supposed to be a
substitute for knowing that maybe what
some people do in fact mean by faith and
they may in fact run their lives and
advise other people to do so according
to that that is not what faith means for
Kierkegaard and it's not what faith
means within the Abraham story so this
entire idea about who Abraham is and why
his story matters is going to be
concerned with this question of figuring
out what faith actually involves and
comprises
you